Mit diesem Mini-U-Boot will Elon Musk bei
der Rettung der
eingeschlossenen Jungen in Thailand helfen.
Der US-Milliardär twitterte am Sonntag ein
Video, das zeigt, wie zwei Taucher das Gerät
durch eine Engstelle bugsieren.
In der Kapsel ist Platz für eine Person.
Musk hatte bereits am Samstag mitgeteilt,
dass ein Team seines privaten Raumfahrtunternehmens
SpaceX an einem Mini-Tauchboot arbeite.
Für den Bau werde man acht Stunden brauchen,
twitterte Musk, 17 weitere Stunden seien für
den Transport nach Thailand nötig.
Bereits in dem asiatischen Land eingetroffen,
sind diese aufblasbaren Rettungskapseln, die
die kalifornische Firma Wing Inflatables in
Zusammenarbeit mit SpaceX entwickelt hat.
Ob die sogenannten Escape-Pods aber auch wirklich
bei der Bergung der seit mehr als zwei Wochen
festsitzenden Jugendfußballmannschaft zum
Einsatz kommen werden, ist bislang unklar.
Unterdessen wurden die Rettungsarbeiten an
der Tham Luang Höhle am Montagvormittag fortgesetzt.
Am Sonntag waren vier Jungen von Rettungstauchern
begleitet in Sicherheit gebracht worden.
Es gehe ihnen gut, teilte der Einsatzleiter
am Montag mit.
Aus Sorge vor möglichen Infektionen dürften
sie jedoch noch nicht zu ihren Eltern.
Acht weitere Kinder und ihr Fußballtrainer
sitzen noch in der Grotte fest.
Der Einsatz, hier Bilder vom Samstag, ist
riskant und langwierig.
Die Taucher müssen durch enge, überflutete
Höhlengänge.
Am vergangenen Freitag war ein ehemaliger
Taucher der Spezialeineinheit Thai Navy Seals
in der Höhle tödlich verunglückt.